في المنزل الذكي ، ليس هناك الكثير الذي
لا يمكنك التحكم فيه ، ولكن إذا كنت تريد معرفة
كمية المياه التي تستخدمها قبل وصول فاتورتك ،
فليس هناك الكثير من الخيارات
، ليس لدي أي فكرة عن كمية المياه التي أستخدمها
يوميًا  أعني أن معظم الناس لا
يصححون لا أحد يفعل ذلك ، لذا فإن الشركات الناشئة في مجال التكنولوجيا
تبتكر طرقًا جديدة لمساعدة أصحاب المنازل ،
فنحن لا نجعلك تضع أجهزة استشعار في جميع أنحاء
منزلك ، ما عليك سوى تثبيت Bui في مكان واحد ،
لذلك يخبرك هذا
باستخدام المياه الإجمالي لمنزلك اليوم  مقارنة
بمتوسط السبعة أيام الخاص بك ، من المثير لل
هتمام معرفة ميزانيتك الإجمالية ولكنك تريد أن
عرف كيف تفعل ذلك مقابل جي
انك ، حسنًا ، أخبرني فقط أنني أس
خدم X كمية جالونات من الماء في اليوم لي
لدي أي فكرة عما إذا كان هذا أكثر  أو أقل من
ذلك ، إذا كان هذا جيدًا أو سيئًا
وفقًا لوكالة حماية البيئة ،
فإن متوسط
سرة الأمريكية يستخدم أكثر من 300 جالون من ال
اء يوميًا ، ولكن من أجل تقليص هذه الكمية ، عل
ك أن تعرف بالضبط أين ته
ر المياه كي
يعرف بوي ذلك  كان بالوعة
راني  ng ولم يكن المرحاض ،
لم يكن الحمام ، لذلك
نستخدم التعلم الآلي ونجمع المعلومات حول
تدفق المياه من نقطة واحدة في
منزلك على طول خط المياه الرئيسي ونرسل
كل تلك المعلومات حول تدفق المياه
عبر Wi-Fi  إلى نهايتنا الخلفية ، فإن معظم
التسريبات الشائعة التي نراها هي تشغيل مراحيض
رؤوس رشاشات مكسورة بعد أن يكون هناك
الكثير من الحنفيات المتسربة ورؤوس الدش.
ضغط الماء إذا حدثت كارثة
عندما تكون بعيدًا ، يمكنك إغلاق
المياه بهاتفك بينما يمكن أن
تكلف التسريبات مئات الدولارات كتعويضات
ورسوم هذه الأنظمة لا تأتي بعوامة رخيصة
والزعانف ستعيدك أكثر من
ثمانمائة دولار و  هذا لا يشمل
التثبيت ، لذلك كنت تتحدث في وقت سابق
عن كيفية استخدام العوامة ، يمكنك تقليل
استخدامك للمياه بنسبة 10 في المائة كم من
المال ، ثم تقوم بتوفير ذلك إذا كنت تعيش
في منطقة بها بالفعل نسبة عالية من المياه
الأسعار
التي توفرها من خلال توفير هذا 10٪ الذي يوفر
حوالي 300 دولار سنويًا على فاتورة المياه الخاصة بك
للأشخاص الذين يتطلعون إلى الحد من البصمة البيئية الخاصة بهم ،
يمكن أن تلعب مثل هذه الأجهزة دورًا مهمًا في
الحفاظ على مورد ثمين